ملامح الحزن والالم وخيبه الامل تبدو
واضحه على ملامح الطفل محمد عقيد الذي فقد
كل عائلته في جنديرس السوريه محمد لم يكن
يتوقع ان تنقلب حياته بين ليله وضحاها
ليصبح يتيما بعد ان كانت الطفل المدلل في
وسط عائلته ليجد نفسه اليوم بدون ماوى بعد
الزلزال الذي حول منزله الى حطام راح بين
ركامه والداه وشقيقاته وتبقى له من اسرته
زوجه عمي والدته ياسمين مرجان من قرخانه
التركيه
انا تركيا انا واطفالي انهدم بنا المنزل
في جنديرس وليس لدينا اي مكان للبقاء فيه
ليس لدينا منزل اريد الخروج من المستشفى
لكن للاسف ليس لدينا مكان ياوينا اريد ان
تتم مساعدته هذا الطفل
محمد بعد ان كان وحيدا لاهله اصبح وحيدا
لزوجه عمي والدته التركيه الاصل وهما
الناجيان الوحيدان من كل الاسره جراء
الزلزال المدمر في ناحيه جنديرس السوريه
لم يتبقى لنا شيء لا اريد الخروج من
المستشفى حتى تتحسن صحه ابني انا تركيا
وبسوريا ليس لدينا اشخاص نذهب عندهم اريد
ان يتم تقديم المساعدات لي
هول الصدمه لا يزال باديا عجز عن الكلام
والتعبير فالموقف لا تقوى تلك الملامح على
تحمله او حتى على الاقل تقبله